well a lot of fitness lovers in our area
just aren't making the drive to the gym
anymore instead the gym
is coming to them that is the concept
for the owner of fit to you
eight news now reporter victoria saha
has our story
fit to you fitness at your convenience
wherever you want
make it convenient for the client make
it a fun experience nice and tight with
the elbow
a mobile gym ceo robby heaton started
right before the pandemic shut
everything down but unlike other
businesses taking a hit
he says the pandemic actually helped him
people felt
safe in a one-on-one setting whether it
was at a park or their house you know a
little more controlled
his mobile gym is packed with different
equipment you won't have to wait for
equipment to free up
like you normally would at a busy gym
five nice
six full range heeden says for busy
parents this is a great option to keep
your eyes on your kids
as well as your fitness goals but it's
not a spur of the moment decision
you will need to sign up in advance
green
you know they can check on their kids
every few minutes or one lady where
i train her and her husband in the
garage and they just put up like a high
chair for their baby
for client john freeman this erases his
gym commute
he would just go to my house and we were
just trained in my backyard or my garage
red red
his workouts are very short high intense
and
they're very fun they require a lot of
thinking and as life starts to go back
to normal and
folks head back into the gyms heeden
says his clients
are here to stay for 8 news now i'm
victoria saha
brian and ted were over there like okay
we're going to start to add this to our
to our routine got some ideas at that
one it's at
your convenience wherever really you
want but it comes at a
pretty hefty price it starts at 110 for
each
six sessions it would well it's like a
mobile gym at your doorstep really
we will have information up on our
website for you at 8newsnow.com
right we should um says we're going to
try those moves
don't know if we'll succeed in north los